we have decided that teacher
assessed grade center assessed grades
the grades that schools
and colleges uh uh set as being the
grade they thought
students would achieve an exam should be
awarded
for gcses and a levels and asses
b texts are not affected by this
decision
these are unprecedented circumstances
the task we attempted to do was to
set exam grades with no exams taking
place
we developed an approach that has been
used in other countries as well
but it is clear that while it may have
technical merits
for in some ways but it is simply has
not been
a an acceptable experience for young
people and we have therefore decided
that we should change course and allow
the
center assessed grades to be awarded i
would like to say
sorry we have recognized the
uh difficulty that young people have
faced uh coping
with the receipts of grades that they
were unable to understand the the basis
on which they had been awarded
well it's been our political
correspondent joe pike who joins me now
from westminster an apology from aqua
there uh an expected u-turn joe yeah
kemal this is embarrassing but it was
inevitable scotland did this with the
hires last week reverting to teacher
assessed grades the welsh government
announced earlier this afternoon
they are doing the same and we expect a
similar decision to be announced
in northern ireland in the next 10
minutes
or so the education unions have already
uh welcomed this the naht the national
association of head teachers
saying these teach recessed grades are
the most reliable measures this is the
only option that the government
had left but they say why has this
decision
taken so long to come you'll remember
that gavin williamson the education
secretary
said on saturday just two days ago no
u-turn
no change well now we know the u-turn
has certainly happened and it is a
screeching u-turn
it doesn't no mean that all the
headaches are over for
the government because university places
are limited there will be universities
who will have all of their places full
based on grades which
are not the final grades of some
students there may not be places for
students who had
who have better grades now than they did
when they got their results
last week they could also be students
who've already accepted
a backup offer at a less prestigious
institution
and now realize they maybe could have
gone to their first
choice so a lot of headaches for
students for universities
and still gamal for the department of
education
okay joe thank you